peut-être
[Musique]
en fait quel est le nom de cette étrange
instrument qu'il avait ça s'appelle la
cornemuse à gaz exane et de l'inventaire
et comment vous est venue l'idée de
fabriquer un tel instrument
oh ben ça date déjà depuis longtemps ma
grand-mère jouer de la cornemuse et moi
même je suis un enfant de la commune
alors je me souviens à jouer j'ai mis
longtemps à fabriquer ces instruments au
assez longtemps sa demande est quand
même pas mal de soirée et le dimanche
est ce que pointent maintenant oui
malgré quelques petites retouches dans
les notes
quels sont les avantages de cet
instrument ben ça pas mal davantage vu
que le bourdon est quand même assez
réduit ça permet de passer sous les
portes et sont moins encombrants et
aussi c'est beaucoup moins fatigant du
moment qui a pu la poche à remplir
j'ai plus qu'à ouvrir une bouteille la
poche remplie et ça me permet aussi en
même temps de de chanter dessus de fumer
la cigarette au besoin parce que c'est
pas dangereux et du gaz que le v là au
nom du moment donné par l'intérieur vous
pensez que ça aura du succès un seuil
est très certainement oui j'ai déposé un
brevet oui oui il est parti et je pense
que ça marchera peut-être dans le cadre
de la régionalisation peut être votre
cas est une industrie nouvelle pour la
bretagne et moi euh comment ça
fonctionne exactement 20 ça fonctionne
par les bouteilles j'ouvre mes
bouteilles ça remplit la poche et ça
nous permet de jouer
vous pouvez nous faire une démonstration
vaut bien celui là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
qu'est-ce qui se passe j'ai plus de
gosses c'est la panne je obligé
d'ailleurs rechange et une bouteille
[Musique]